es ist kurz vor sieben gestern morgen
als der lufthansa airbus auf der südbahn
des frankfurter flughafens aufsetzt an
bord etwa 300 geflüchtete aus
afghanistan ortskräfte und ihre
angehörigen mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen von hilfsorganisationen
als die maschine am geld anlegt wissen
wir noch nicht ob auch der mann an bord
ist um dessen schicksal wir seit wochen
bangen der familienvater nadschibullah
anssari
vier tage ist es her dass wir eine
verzweifelte nachricht von ihm bekommen
haben mitten aus dem tode des chaos des
kabuler flughafens
es ist das totale chaos sie sagen es
würde keine fliege aber
hier fliegen jede stunde fünf oder sechs
flieger nur uns sagen sie es gibt nichts
es sind tage der angst
hunderttausende afghanen sind auf der
flucht auch viele die wir noch vor
kurzem getroffen hatten das sind ihre
geschichten
in einer kleinen wohnung in teheran
treffen wir lange und romina osmani wo
sie mit ihrer familie zuflucht gefunden
haben vor ein paar wochen noch hatten
wir die beiden schwestern in herat
kennengelernt schon damals ist klar auf
der todesliste der taliban stehen die
beiden frauenrechtlerinnen ganz oben
als ihre heimatstadt vor zwei wochen
eingenommen wird flüchten die frauen mit
ihren familien auf dem landweg über die
iranische grenze nach maschad und später
nach tiere die straßen werden da längst
von den taliban kontrolliert es sind
stunden voller todesangst erzählen uns
die frauen
den ganzen weg über hatte ich angst dass
wir uns aus dem auto holen und vor den
augen meiner kinder erschießen
fassungslos verfolgen sie die
nachrichten aus der heimat versuchen
kontakt zu halten mit denen die
zurückgeblieben sind und zu begreifen
was da in den letzten tagen wirklich
passiert ist
es ist wie ein alptraum aus dem man
nicht aufwacht egal wie sehr man es
versucht keiner von uns hatte das so
kommen sehen es müssen so viele menschen
gewesen sein die uns betrogen haben die
hätten das doch niemals geschafft wenn
da nicht auch leute aus der regierung
geholfen hätten
wir werden lange und die anderen später
noch einmal treffen als sie sich auf den
weg machen zur deutschen botschaft hier
in teheran freunde hatten ihn ein video
des deutschen außenministers geschickt
in dem er verspricht afghanische
geflüchtete auch aus den nachbarländern
zu retten
auch heuer hatten wir vor ein paar
wochen noch in afghanistan getroffen
niemals werde sie ihr land verlassen
hatte uns die junge fotojournalistin
damals erzählt trotz todesdrohungen
wollte sie hier bleiben ein vorbild sein
für junge mädchen ihre geschichten
erzählen mit ihren fotos ihnen ein
gesicht geben
doch als die taliban die stadt erobern
schickt sie uns nachrichten voller angst
und panik immer wieder versucht sie an
den flughafen zu gelangen nach tagen
schafft sie es mit hilfe der franzosen
auf einen flieger wird über abu dhabi in
die nähe von paris gebracht in eine
unterkunft für geflüchtete für zehn tage
in quarantäne
als wir ja hier treffen ist die kaum
wiederzuerkennen immer wieder verschiebt
sie das gespräch mit uns vor der kamera
will sie nicht sprechen sie sei zu
aufgewühlt erst am nächsten tag schickt
sie uns eine sprachnachricht
ich kann nicht wirklich schlafen es ist
immer noch wie ein alptraum was wenn ich
mein land nie wiedersehe ich bin so
verzweifelt weil ich nicht für mein land
und die menschen dort tun kann meine
jüngere schwester studentin nachdem die
taliban das land übernommen haben darf
sie nicht mehr in die uni ich mache mir
sorgen um ihre zukunft
es sind zahllose dramatische schicksale
in diesen tagen auch das des bundeswehr
übersetzers nadschibullah ansary der
mann auf den wir im flieger nach
frankfurt hoffen in einem safe house an
einem geheimen ort in kabul hatten wir
ihn zuletzt mit seiner frau und seinen
beiden kindern getroffen ihre
heimatstadt masar i scharif hatten sie
verlassen müssen aus angst vor
racheakten der taliban
die mussten fliehen als die taliban
alles eingenommen haben sie hätten unser
haus niedergebrannt und die ganze
familie ausgelöscht
nachdem die taliban vor zehn tagen kabul
eingenommen haben musste die familie
raus aus dem schutzraum wirte tage lang
durch die stadt auch ihnen gelingt es
nicht in den flughafen zu kommen immer
wieder schickt uns der familienvater
fotos und verzweifelte nachrichten
[Musik]
all die menschen die familien stehen vor
dem flughafen und kommen nicht rein
und dann hat es plötzlich doch geklappt
gestern früh die nachricht aus frankfurt
sie haben es geschafft terminal 2 halle
ehe die antaris waren tatsächlich an
bord von masar i scharif über kabul und
taschkent nach frankfurt wochen der
angst wochen der flucht gehen zu ende
die erschöpfung aber ist nadschibullah
deutlich anzumerken
[Musik]
gott ich bin froh dass wir hier in
deutschland sind
ich kann gar nicht glauben dass wir hier
sind
aber gut geht es mir trotzdem nicht ich
habe schlimme dinge erlebt
ich werde wohl ein paar tage brauchen um
zur ruhe zu kommen
er wolle jetzt richtig gut deutsch
lernen erzählt uns nadschibullah zum
abschied noch in afghanistan hätten er
und seine familie keine zukunft mehr
tehran heute morgen mit ihren papieren
machen sich lange romina und die anderen
auf den weg zur deutschen botschaft
im iran kann die familie nicht bleiben
das land will keine weiteren
geflüchteten aus afghanistan aufnehmen
sie hoffe deshalb auf ein visum für
deutschland erzählt uns leid aber es
wird klar wie sehr der verlust der
heimat sie schmerzt
das wort flüchtling fühlt sich komisch
an für mich und auch ein bisschen
kränkend aber ich fürchte ich muss mich
daran gewöhnen aber
es ist nicht nur ein wort an dass sie
sich gewöhnen müssen es ist ein völlig
neues leben und dies sind nur drei
geschichten von hunderttausenden